and each one is firmly established on
the breakdancing scene in Malmo a
veteran at the age of 12 he and his
six-year-old brother Kenzo are part of a
generation that could see breakdancing
or breaking as it's known complete an
unlikely journey to the Olympics with
final approval for the Paris 2024 Summer
Games expected in a year's time yeah my
age 16 around so I would complete the
Olympics so you're gonna be winning
breaking medals for sweet the Bears are
highly practice Malmo is hosting the
undisputed masters an unofficial
end-of-year World Championship
competitive breaking is run by different
promoters scattered across the globe but
the license for the Olympics has been
applied for by the world dance sport
Federation which usually organizes
ballroom dancing this has always been a
culture not a sports meaning it has no
ruling body as such but with the
ballroom dancing Federation taking it
into the Olympics many fear that
breaking and could be forgetting its
roots the dangers part of it is if we
lose our touch we lose what this dance
is really about then that's when we lose
culture then that's when we lose the
lifestyle but this dance really
represents which is an avenue out from
people and garrow's right from people
that come from impoverished backgrounds
we have to keep that part alive and I
don't think you could be that successful
without really earning the respect of
the community or the culture that people
that really live
the culture is also being lived in
countries like Nisha and Cameroon these
are some of the places in which the
Olympics could provide exposure and
aspiration for braking harnessing its
competitive element just as long as
going into the games doesn't make it all
about medals and money only commercial
people know it's not gonna work because
the community will not last but if it's
the right people behind it and doing a
good job and the people in the community
trust them yes this tell me of that
happened it's gonna be good the world's
DanceSport Federation has already
organized breaking out the Youth
Olympics with the help of the community
it will find out if it wins the battle
for the real thing next December Paul
Reis al Jazeera Malmo Sweden